in 2000 yeltsin
was no longer president and vladimir
putin became president
you did
a series of interviews with vladimir
putin as you mentioned
over a period of two years from 2015 to
2017.
let's let me ask with a high-level
question
what was your goal
with that conversation oh uh came out in
2017 i guess i started him in 2014
at that point
the snowden affair had happened i was
working on a movie on snowden that
happened in 13.
uh ukraine uh happened in 14.
and uh
one thing after another by by 14
putin was enemy number again becoming a
wanted man on the american list he was
enemy
he was certainly in the top five or uh
and but the the animosity towards putin
had been growing since 2007 at munich
i remember that speech when he made it
it's in my documentary that's a
four-hour documentary four different
conversations i mean we talked over two
years two and a half years but i
remember that image of him at munich
making a very
important speech about world harmony
about the balance necessary in the world
and i remember the sneer
the sneer on john mccain's face he was
in munich
obviously eyeballing putin and hating
him and it was so evident that mccain
had no belief whatsoever that the that
this he was almost treating him like
this or the communists are back and we
know that putin was not a communist we
know that putin is very much a market
man and he made no he he made it very
clear and tried to keep an open climate
a new relationship with europe but the
united states always certain people in
the united states always sell that as a
threat like putin is trying to take
europe away from us as if we own it as
if we have the right to own it but pun
was making the point it's very important
about sovereignty and
sovereignty for
countries is crucial to for for this new
world to have balance that's sovereignty
for china sovereignty for russia
sovereignty for iran sovereignty for
venezuela sovereignty for cuba this is
an idea that's crucial to the new world
and i think the united states has never
accepted that
sovereignty is not an idea
that they can allow they you have to be
obedient to the united states idea
of so-called democracy and uh freedom
but
the it's much more important is
sovereignty for these countries and the
united states has not obeyed that as not
has not even acknowledged it
and it never comes up so from the
perspective of the united states when
power centers arise in the world yes
you start to oppose those
not because of the ideas but because
they have but merely because they have
power
isn't that at the heart of the doctrine
of the uh neoconservatives and they knew
the pact for the new american century
they wrote that in 1996
seven
they said there shall be no emergence of
a rival power it was very clear it was
about power
and they have they've stuck to that
doctrine which is if you if you start to
get dangerous in any way or have power
we're going to knock you out
now that won't work but i i don't
believe it can work and that is
unfortunately a policy the united states
is following
and uh the neoconservatives group which
is very small but it's very strong
apparently and their idea has resonated
it was it was behind the george bush's
invasion of
iraq
it was part of not only iraq but
cleaning out the whole world draining
the swamp
going to afghanistan first and then
although
iraq had nothing to do with al-qaeda's
attack going after iraq
and of course 60 some other countries
that where terrorism had some
had some
signs of
wherever america judged would be a
dangerous country we had the right
you're either with us or against us now
that is a disastrous policy and led to
one thing after another the iraq war
never learned a lesson
the neoconservatives were never fired
never thrown out of office the people
who
prosecuted that war are still around
many of them are still around and
they're they're obviously guiding
america now let me return to this
question of power
don't forget
the sneer that i saw there
that emblemized the united states
reaction also there were several other
american representatives who were
laughing kind of mocking uh putin it was
very serious i i felt
that was a divide there
so
since then i mean in a certain sense the
europe reaction to putin is crucial and
they were they were more with him back
then and
a big thing for america was always to
keep nato to keep europe in its pocket
as a satellite and with this recent war
of course they've succeeded
in in all beyond their dreams if the
russians have fulfilled the fantasy of
the united states to finally be this
aggressor that they have pictured for
years yeah we can talk about that later
but at that time
there was uh europe had significant
support for putin yes the united states
was sneering at putin
that's correct you can say that and then
so there's this um
it was
um
there was uncertainty as to the
direction as to the future of russia and
that's exactly when you interviewed
vladimir putin i wanted to know
what they thought because we couldn't
get the
the in the information war that the
united states was fighting against
russia was in evidence back then it was
full out the the condemnation of russia
on all fronts i never saw a positive
article about putin and although when i
traveled in the world and i traveled a
lot doing documentaries it was very
clear in the middle east in africa in
other in asia there was respect for him
that he was a man who was getting job
his job done in the interests of russia
he was as i said in the documentary a
son of russia
very much so in in the positive sense a
son a son of russia not that he's out
there
trying to uh destroy the interests of
other of other countries know that he
was out there to
sell the promote the interests of russia
but at the same time keep a balance keep
it
keep it keep the world into a harmony
this has always been his picture peace
was always his idea in other words he
always referred to the united states in
all these interviews as our partners and
i said will you stop using that word
they're not
well and he was a little bit slow in
waking up to
what the united states was doing well
that said he's one of the most powerful
men in the world
he was at that time
and
let me ask you the human question
as the old adage goes power corrupts and
absolute power corrupts absolutely
did you see
any corroding effects of power on the
man
forget the political leader i'm just the
human being that carries that power on
his shoulders
for so many years keep in mind that he's
been un
unlike most modern leaders he's been in
office
off and on because of there was a
medvedev was president and he was not
literally in charge
he was
he was he was uh he took another
appointment at that point and he but he
was still very much involved but for 20
years more or less he's been at the
administrator of the state the protector
of the state
and he's apparently done
a good enough job that the russian
people have kept him there because
contrary to what many people think i
really believe that if the russian
people didn't want him he would be out
i firmly believe that i don't think you
can let you can go against the will of
the people now it expresses itself in
many ways
at the ballot box and so forth but also
in other ways in russia there's a
strong occurrence of opinion so contrary
to what the
the
position of him as a dictator he
wouldn't last if he was unpopular number
one number two russia is much more
divided than people know there's other
factors in russia he is there's there
are always tensions in in around the
kremlin
who has power who doesn't have power
that's been going on for
100 years but
the the factions in russia are
very much there so when people refer to
russia as putin they're they're mistaken
and they do this regularly in the new
york papers and all this so they say
putin did this putin did that putin's
doing it but it's russia that's doing it
and that's what there's a distinction
there that i
it's changed in the old days
i would read about khrushchev but it was
never khrushchev personally
it was about the soviet union
uh there was respect for a country and
now when it started to get personal with
putin
it it changed it and the our thinking
changed in a negative way we
we no longer respected it as a country
we were seen as a man and the man we had
trashed repeatedly
repeatedly as a poisoner as a murderer
and none of which has ever been proven
but which has always been repeated and
repeated to the point at which it
becomes like an orwell
mantra it becomes like he is of course a
bad guy
can i just ask you as a great filmmaker
as a human being what was it like
talking to one of the most powerful men
in the world
for honestly and i'm not naive i've
talked to a lot of powerful people
in the movie business there are powerful
people and many of them are corrupted
i've talked to many people in my life
i've been in the military i've seen i've
had other jobs
i have to say i found him to be a human
being i just found him to be reasonable
calm
i never saw him lose his temper and i
mean you have to understand that most
people in the most people in the western
way of doing business
get emotional i don't see that i saw him
as a balanced man as a man who had
studied this like you there's a calmness
to you that it comes from studying the
world and
having a rational response to it
his it's interesting his two daughters
one of them is very scientific and the
other one's doing very well in another
profession but they they're thinking
they're thinking family his wife too was
uh i can't talk for the new wife because
i don't know about it but he's he kept
his family
with great respect he's raised his his
daughter's right
he served yeltsin the way he looks at it
he served yeltsin well and he and he
still and he never trashed well uh
yeltsin certainly a lot of people did
but you know i asked him repeatedly
you know was he an alcoholic and this or
that but he wouldn't even go that far he
just respect
and
this man yeltsin who was in it was uh in
many ways um ridiculed but in by the
russians and
he turned over the power because he felt
like he was overwhelmed he turned over
the power to this man because why how
many people had he fired before him
several
several prime ministers this that why
did he turn power over
to uh mr putin because
he respected him for his work ethic
and his balance his maturity
and that's what i can say is i saw in
him
a a poor person poor from a poor family
who worked his way up
through the kgb of americans keep saying
he's a kgb agent but
it's it's like saying you know george
bush was a cia agent but you know he
became a pr you grow you grow in your
life and he went from the kgb to this
technocratic position he dealt with many
uh problems incl including the chechnyan
war
which was a
very difficult situation as well as
the russian submarine probably several
things happened early in his that
balance that gave him a lot of
experience
and he handled them all pretty well
do you think he was an honest man i do
now of course the question of money of
the charge is that he's the richest man
in the world or ludicrous uh
certainly doesn't live like it or act
like it if you're rich i i've been
around a lot of rich people in my life
you'd probably have too in america you
run into them so many of them are
arrogant i'm actually uh
good friends now with the richest man in
the world oh of course i saw your
interview with mr uh
musk who i i appreciate at least he
speaks really
i i i'm i'm positive about him owning
twitter because twitter has become
censorship
uh city s has all the major tech i mean
the censorship that we are now seeing in
the united states is so un-american
and shocking to me and he's a resistance
to that
yeah i like i like musk for that just
for that only but i also appreciate him
his
adventures from his nature and his
desire to to to explore the world and to
ask questions yeah there's certain ways
you sound when you speak freely
there's certain ways you sound a man
sounds when he speaks freely and he
speaks freely
and it's refreshing yeah no matter
whether you're rich or not it doesn't
matter when you speak freely it's a
beautiful actually you must
a major point on going back to nuclear
energy you know he was
he never believed in it at first
apparently uh he was going for batteries
right and he didn't put a lot of money
into batteries he made them bigger and
bigger batteries but
it just as bill gates has said it's just
it's not going to get us there yeah and
now i think musk is on another path he
understands the need for nuclear yeah
he's a supporter of nuclear
we're jumping around who never asked for
one thing never
it was an interview it was free form i
ask anything you want
no no restrictions no rules
as with castro frankly castro did the
same thing as their chevez so i've had
good luck in interviewing free-ranging
subjects people willing to express
themselves he's much more guarded than
castro
or uh chavez because as you know he he's
he's setting government policy when he
speaks and anything he says is can be
taken out of context
but there was no restrictions on what to
talk about none of that nor any desire
to see anything before we published it
no need to check it with them
it was a
completely
do you think he watched the final
product yes i do but i don't think he
made judgments on it i think he was
pleased
he doesn't go either way you see he's
very it's he's pleased i mean he went
well he's happy for us and but i don't
think he had great enthusiasm uh
expressed it to me and he trusted me and
you can see the way he dealt with me
each time he warmed up to me uh
four times you know the first time i
might have been a little
stiff uh
you're asking uh
you don't know what who you're dealing
with and so forth i understand that but
he's used to it now he's he's done a lot
of press the worst press he's done
frankly has been the american press
and not because of his fault but because
of the way they have treated him if you
look at the interviews they're awful
they put first of all i i noticed one
thing as a filmmaker right away they use
a dub an overdub they put a russian
speaker yeah for everything he says he
was much harsher he speaks russian in a
much harsher manner than actually putin
does yeah who's very if you on my
interview i left him in his original
language with translator and i think
that's important because he expresses
himself very clearly and calmly
when you listen to the american
broadcast it's a belligerent person who
looks like he's about to bang his shoe
on the table
and secondly the questions are
highly aggressive from the beginning
there's no
there's no sense of rapport there's no
sense of well it's why mr poon did you
poison this person why mr putin did you
kill this person why are you a murderer
that means it's blunt
blunt negative television yeah it's not
just aggressive so i
obviously speak russian
so i get to appreciate both the original
and the translation
and uh it's not just aggressive it's
very shallow
they're not looking to understand
to me aggression is okay if that's the
way you want to approach it but it
should be there should be underlying
kind of empathy for another human being
in order to be able to understand
and and so
the the some of the worst interviews
i've ever listened to is by american
press of vladimir putin so nbc
and all those kinds of organizations
it's very painful to watch
and you saw the reception to the putin
interviews in america was hostile
without seeing it
so many people
criticized
my series without having seen it even
even i went on a show a television show
with this famous colbert
you know he's very famous in america and
i was shocked on the show to find out
that he hadn't seen anything of the four
hours he was just attacking putin and
through me
i was complicit therefore i was a
i was a putin supporter and he the show
was a disaster it's it's one of my worst
television shows i
actually
i had to
just shut up and get off the air i mean
at some point it was embarrassing
because the audience too was clapping
for kobe on anything he said well as an
interviewer in that situation because
between you and vladimir putin there was
camaraderie there was joking
there was
are you
worried do you put that into the
calculation when you're making a film
with somebody that could be lying to you
that could be evil
you talk about castro you talk about so
are you worried about how how
charisma of a man across the table from
you
can uh don't take that into account i
absolutely take that into account i know
i mean doing castro's
he's a wonderful speaker he's
charismatic so is chavez i think look at
those interviews
i took it into account but putin doesn't
play that game he doesn't charm you he
doesn't try to overwhelm you with his
um
bonami at all
he just says okay ask your question i'll
give you my answer straight here it is
this and he analyzes it this is the
history of nato this is a history of our
relationship with the united states how
many times have we tried to talk to them
about such and such and such and such
and each time we get nowhere
in fact it's a very
i would like to get along with the
united states so much he's saying that
he's saying it's so clearly in all his
words so to play devil's advocate but
he's not making a big deal about it but
there is a charisma in the calmness yes
there is so like
let's just calm everything down it's
simple facts that you can yes you can
you can call
um
so there's like the hitler thing which
is screaming
being very loud charismatic strong
message and so on and then there's a
putin style i'm not comparing those two
there's the style communication of
calmness
and and that at least to me my
personality that can be very captivating
it's bringing everything down the facts
are simple but then when you say the
facts are simple you can now start lying
and you don't know what's true and
what's wrong
it behooves you to do some research yes
and frankly when coming to research
you're gonna have a problem because if
you go to the americanized versions of
russian history you're going to run into
a problem
and that includes even wikipedia
they will tell you things that are just
not factually supported so it was a
problem in terms of
if you read all the books in the
american the library about putin there's
nothing positive about it uh they awful
they're awful and a lot of them uh i had
a good relationship with professor
stephen cohen who's the most i think one
of the most informed men on russia he's
done a lot of research all his life
and uh knew gorbachev very well
and
was very
ana analytical about all these
situations that happened before his
death in
2019 i'm not quite sure when stephen
died but i knew him well
and uh
he was the he gave me the best
information i could get i would go to
stephen and i'd say
i'm confused here tell me the history of
this accusation of poisoning against
this person and so forth and he'd
explain it to me in i think very the
clearest ways that i understood and he
said to me once he said most of these
people who go to russia and write this
stuff about putin are going off internet
the internet has really been a source of
a lot of fractured facts here
uh he said pure analysis you have to go
back to the texts
all the documents
and to really fully understand but he un
he
spoke russian
and his wife and him uh
katarina
catarina
van gaal who's the editor
publisher of the nation magazine would
go to russia several times
a year and talked to their friend
gorbachev and gorbachev's an interesting
character i've talked to him interviewed
him not interviewed him but talked to
him at length and i like him very much
and i saw the divide as you saw in the
putin interviews between gorbachev and
putin early on in the interviews you
sense putin doesn't particularly care
for governor chuck because he in his
point of view he screwed up the
administration of russia and is
responsible for so much
of the disaster of leaving all those
people outside the soviet union
so
these are problems that continue into
the future but
he
at the they see each other at the or he
sees he knows he's there at the may day
parade i i we filmed and uh he's is he
he
his attitude is funny he's very human
he says i you know he's welcome he's god
he's got he's pension he's a pensioner
he's done his duty he's there's no
there's no uh
animus towards him
even when gorbachev in the early days
you remember criticized him for his
manners in terms of democracy
but i don't know that that
you know that becomes a quarrel but
frankly by the
by the end of the situation uh it's very
clear that gorbachev has now moved
closer and closer to the says russia is
now really under attack this is
he sees it he sees where the united
states has made a concerted effort to
undermine putin and he does and has he's
repeated this several times about
ukraine i think you've seen what he said
you can quote it
and gorbachev is we have no respect for
gorbachev even even at this juncture
when can you see gorbachev's ideas
printed in most american newspapers very
rarely very rarely and not and recently
not at all so gorbachev who was our hero
back in in the american hero back in
1980s
80s
has now been condemned to the garbage
can so to speak of history
you